this pandemic will and already is
changing us society I don't mean the
economy or social distancing I mean
privacy our freedoms these are now a
danger to our health
this isn't about judgment condemnation
or endorsement this is a global health
crisis many lives are at stake
and desperate times call for desperate
measures but look and see what's
happening before our very own eyes
troops and armored vehicles on the
streets of Western cities drones
patrolling cities and ordering civilians
to return to their homes
[Laughter]
nationwide lockdowns police and troops
detaining civilians for violating
curfews not in the Middle East or China
but in Europe in Italy alone more than a
hundred thousand people have been
charged for violating the lockdown
drones monitor citizens from above where
they walk their dogs where they park
where they congregate governments are
telling neighbors and friends and family
to report each other if they find out
someone violated quarantine we have
created an online reporting portal where
people can submit a form to advise of
any gatherings that are not in adherence
with the guidance and eased the demand
on one on one
all of this was completely unimaginable
a few months ago but it's all about
stopping the virus at whatever cost in
the fight against this sanitary crisis
it is paramount that we anticipate the
spread of the pandemic and it's likely
peak in each country in Israel
they've started tracking people's
movements with their phones to catch
those violating quarantine or to warn
people who've been near someone who was
infected in America in Europe in Russia
they're talking about doing the same
thing our mobile phones have been turned
into tracking devices for our own good
they say it's hard to argue with it and
personally for the duration of the
crisis I don't mind my question isn't
when this will end this total control my
question is will it end the European
data protection supervisor often
stresses that such developments usually
do not contain the possibility to step
back when the emergency is gone how
often the government's or police give up
powers you don't need me to answer that
you know full well yourself we're all
afraid we're all confused and worried
for our loved ones fear has gripped our
world our society because of that
we have given up without complaint our
freedoms to our governments for our own
good I'm not here to judge I'm only
stating the obvious with the hope that
when this nightmare is over and that
fear passes we'll get our freedoms back
you